"...Because in the same shot, he's supposed
to get sprayed with the blood." James Cullen Bressack and
I wrote both the scripts and the
distributors that we didn't end up
selling the film to I approached and
said hey if I made a film in the same
genre would you buy it and they said yes
and so they pre bought the film
all right guys wardrobe is clear make
something later
quiet freeze lock it up bear line when
they're walking away where he's like
move your ass and pushes him into the
room with that weight from them to these
guys during that whole exchange then
we're going to get a shot of them
Wow Claire can you do that health again
all right